hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to
resident evil village we are hanging out
just having a good time
i discovered that it actually wasn't the
end of the game just then and there
i think it's like a post-credit sequence
where you just uh get to experience
the joy oh
of creation
oh god
wow my bad hand
that hand was already boned all right
it's okay i'll just grow some fungus out
of it
yeah i don't know about you but if if if
something split this hand here
these thingies ain't working too good oh
that'll do the trick blue
save some for the other hand oh
instantly better
oh good you ever wonder what's in those
things you know
maybe it's not so uh unzombie-like
remember when this was about zombies
do you guys remember that the whole
zombie thing oh
lady demitriscu found your glass
you'll want this back i know you will
this is a switch but it ain't do nothing
all right well lady damn etruscan wow
you know this door i thought it was
uh small is apparently normal size
anyway
are these her gloves what power what is
that
the blood on the fruit what unique and
interesting tastes
this blood tea oh it's blood tea isn't
it
that's hilarious
locked from the other side huh so says
you so says you
hmm lockpick luck
man i remember when i had a whole kit a
whole lock picking kit
that was nice oh
okay oh hello ah
on my belly getting my getting my nice
wounded hands
in the rat muck that's always a good
spot
is that a foot yeah that's fine
you guys got any bags of flour around
here oh rusted scrap
don't know how i saw that well
this all looks good hello hi oh
yeah i'll take that
uh okay so squeeze me
squeezy me excuse me
well lady dimmer rescue
oh
sure thing sure thing that makes sense
whatever that was hello
how you doing oh i'll take that yes i'm
gonna need some of that
uh pardon me oh yeah that's worth some
money
not that i need the money yeah where are
they
i'm sorry hello welcome to the party
where'd you come from
all right nice baps okay one
two is this another puzzle it's another
puzzle isn't it okay
well i don't have what i need for that
okay what did this say mask the angels
blinded
mask the angels blatant gaze and only
then you will be saved will you be saved
whatever did i get everything over here
i don't know that i did but then again i
don't know a lot of things so i'm going
to forget
about it i'm going to go upstairs or i'm
going to go over here
i'm going to ignore that the sounds of
other doors sounding like they're
opening
wait where did that come from where did
i go
we meet again duke
why are you here well there's coin to be
made
and have you found your daughter no
if she is truly here the lady of the
castle would have kept little rose in
her private chambers
would she not tell me trusk the very
same
why don't you take a look maybe you'll
get lucky
and speaking of looking care to make a
purchase
lady domitresque lady domitrisk
lady dimitrescu of the of the ducks dug
down
demotress condom shall i choose
something for you
shall you choose something for me now
let's get on get ahead of ourselves here
um i should probably get the shotgun
amro
recipe yeah i should definitely get the
recipe because that's going to help i
can see why you'd be interested in that
can you guess what i'd be interested in
you can see
yeah you can see i can see you
don't moan while i'm looking at your
shop
it makes it very awkward no i'm a
dimitra's
i'm not going to do dometress this is
dimitrescu uh
i'm not gonna sell this glass i gotta
give it back
i gotta give it back um i could use more
oh actually i can't use more bullets
securing goods is more important than
anything
anything my friend each bullet costs a
hundred and fifty lay
lay doesn't grow on trees you know yeah
whatever okay
all right later dude don't know how you
got in here
what is this norrish haynes labyrinths a
craftsman of the late 19th century
norshtain was branded a heretic in his
homeland
he wandered the lands until he settled
in a remote village norshtain
then created four labyrinths the castle
the house on the hill the water wheel
and the iron tower
upon their completion he put a gun to
his temple and took their own his own
life
this sounds a lot like the story of
harry potter in like the four houses of
hogwarts but
i don't think that that well kill me
harry
kill me give me harry each labyrinth is
unique and requires its own specially
crafted metal ball
to operate each one contains
crystallized human remains
human balls which are said to be
norshtain's four beloved balls the
labyrinths are their graves no
he was also a polygamist i can't believe
this
okay four wives four labyrinths their
graves okay
i get it i get it i get it it makes
sense whatever
oh well that's fancy that looks lovely
oh god what the hell oh wow that's
horrifying i'm gonna i'm not gonna sell
too much more to this dude because i
don't really know
what i'm supposed to sell and what i'm
not supposed to sell so i'm gonna
i'm just gonna ignore you where's your
horse how did you get here how where
where this door clearly couldn't have
worked what
are you okay i'm gonna leave now i gotta
go find my baby or something
lady dimmer trescue you give me back my
freaky baby
you give me back my fungus baby mushroom
baby you give a background i'll break
your [ __ ]
okay all right i'm serious hey you're
gonna take me
seriously hey i'm not messing around
lady this is serious business i
unlocked it all right well that's a
shortcut
[Music]
okay lady demitrescue
lady demon rescue all right i'll go
upstairs
i'll do what you ask you rogue
you knave hello
lovely place beautiful halls
grand manor
ah yeah give me dad
ah poopy why are all these rooms locked
what's it with resident evil unlocked
rooms uh yeah
thank you lady demon rescue i'm breaking
your stuff you better stop me
you better come over here and arrest me
i'm not fair i'm being a very bad man
i'm i'm being bad no it's not
oh hi um i can't use this as
is well i know about that then
let's take a look at you
well got that now cool maroon eye
glad that was simple good thing my hand
is fine
creepy hi yeah good thing there were
bullets in there
hey what's up can i get in thank you
i kind of got startled before that
happened
i haven't cut open a man in a while
i've never cut open a lady slice your
jugular
oh the graphics what the hell
why the graphics go poop my frame rate
what'd you do to my frames
ah my frames her attack texture frames
directly
you can't hold back any longer what do
you mean
wine room meet me in the wine room
where'd you go
are you gone what the hell happened
okay the wine making techniques have
castled him just i'm talking about wine
now can be traced as far back as the
15th century
long before the current occupants of the
castle alcina dina trescu lou uses this
legendary yet peculiar technique to
enrich the wines flavor
intensity and bestow it with a thick
bouquet
her best vintage is sweat sandwich
virginis
meaning maiden's blood
it is kept in a special ornate bottle
decorated with intricate silver flowers
right sure yeah okay hey y'all got any
of that sanguis
you guys the sanguchi the maiden goose
you got that where'd you go lady
you need to hold back any longer what
what is happening in this
place ah it's happening again
[Applause]
[Laughter]
don't attack my frames you leave my
frames alone lady
i'm strong you see that
are you licking your chaps
you'll never find me down here your bugs
can't reach me
it was my first day working at the
castle today i was most shocked to see
the other staff were all women
the mistress and her daughters were very
adamant that they wouldn't bite
it was peculiar it's been two weeks
since i started working at the castle
and i am a little
afraid another maid adalah
made a mistake and miss daniela slashed
her face with a knife
and at night i can hear wailing as if
ghosts roam the halls
i want to go home i don't know what to
do the young ladies were complaining it
was too hot and stuffy during dinner so
i opened the window just to crack
shut it shut it now they all shrieked at
me in unison
i fear i may be taken down into the
cellar never to be seen of again
i don't know what to do i don't know
what to do i know what to do
open the window perfect a breeze will
take care of these ladies
easy
am i recording good good what is this
strange
noise that i am hearing
[Music]
sure i'm doing a lot of crawling hey hey
hey
is that lady trust you
hello my lady oh wait no lady come back
lady come back no not again ah
just missed her i'll get her soon
did you get a fine v
well they aren't eaten so don't think
that was
lady demidom's doing but uh if that's
what she likes and
who am i to judge
okay can i play your music again will
that bring you back okay whatever
fine i'll move on these developers know
these developers know they know what
they're doing not that i know what
they're doing
they're making a good game with
interesting characters that's what
that's what they're doing
nothing else there's nothing else going
on there's nothing else going on at all
hey this is a cool place let me make the
shadows go whoosh
wow look at that that's cool what am i
doing here
oh hey you okay buddy you all right pal
man you got caught in the middle of all
this all right well
oh trust in light
ah oh
do i gotta light these somehow
it's like a physics puzzle oh there we
go
oh there we go perfect
oh hey ah thanks dude
don't cut me it's kind of dark
you said trust in light and it's real
dork
oh there i go yeah it seems like oh
let me hop right in it's covered in
dried blood this
this seems fun oh that seems real fun oh
hey look at that yeah that's
this is great stuff
real good at least they gave him a
toilet
oh yeah this is great stuff
let me in hello
i stabbed the pooper i stabbed the
pooper
i stab it i stabbed the pooper
i stop okay whatever don't even look
like poop in there oh you didn't finish
your food
i stabbed the food
i stabbed the soup okay i'm going to
stab
you and uh i guess that's just about it
i don't know what kind of experiments
oh arena robust appetite
mihayla robust appetite lois robust
appetite
ingrid unstable overly alert at times
no appetite at all
i stab attite
[Music]
i stab the body i stab the body
oh [ __ ]
i stabbed the [ __ ] who's there huh
ah
hang on i gotta check every single one
of these goddamn
cells
oh you know i'm pretty sure i actually
already
oh that wasn't rusted was it okay i see
it's much more special
i stabbed the box i stabbed the noise
come at me try me you won't you did you
tried
and failed bam
boom bang boom ah you know what you need
a few more lessons
you know i would stay you got a big
stabber
oh shoot is this a dead end
whoa
joke's on you oh god okay you missed
too bad too bad for you okay cool
hey thanks for the what
thing i'm dope as hell hey did i knock
that weapon out of their hand
okay uh what are you ingrid you all seem
very attentive
your name ingrid i
stop it oh [ __ ] man that would have been
really useful
that would have been incredibly useful
don't make me stab you
i will do it i will absolutely do it i'm
going to do it
nice the woman
man i don't know i stab
i stab slice
i stab still oh
[ __ ] try me don't don't try me
push push nah it's not working
i wasn't really pushing anybody whoa
nice
battle axe
close the door on you shoot
all right i'm gonna finish you off with
some stuff oh god did i parry that did i
parry that i did not period i took i
definitely took damage from that
i stabbed all right cool oh
ingrid ingrid it was you
where is your appetite see you didn't
eat this is what happened to you
oh look at that you're nothing but dust
you wasted away
your damn appetite wasn't up to snuff
i'm sorry
oh my god how many more are they
uh hello can i help you
stab oh hoophole escape hole
escape hole can i go down there nah
someone i can stat you get stabbed oh
god
ah see i can dodge you whoa
i can definitely dodge you
missed me by that much
oh this is a great strategy no
wow good thing my my arms are very sword
proof
and stab the butt stab
don't try it you know ingrid you're no
ingrid at all
all right oh okay that was just the dust
okay so now that i know i'm more than a
challenge for these
very slow shambling monsters
i feel very confident to uh
to face any monstrosity that comes my
way from now on until the end of the
game
clearly i am surprised i can't believe
cassandra caused all this
mess cause cassandra
hey don't attack my frames i'll mess
with my frames
hey no no what does no mean blood
warm wet bright red blood
all right you know what i'm very curious
but you know i got i
can't i i i'm in a committed
relationship and i'm
i can't sorry excuse me
hey i was gonna get those
your bullets cannot harm
okay so you don't like windows is the
breeze too much for you
oh i'm sorry is it a little too breezy
in here
it's pertinent man yeah i'm a man yeah
what of it
i'm not even smiling whoa ow i won't
out okay you really kind of hurt
am i supposed to leave or something am i
am i supposed to leave
hey hey hey hey hey you cut that [ __ ]
and not my [ __ ] either don't cut my [ __ ]
don't cut my [ __ ] slice your throat
and stuff it with worms
worms huh very fun
you okay no
i'm
well yeah but you know you don't feel
pain how can you feel anything else
miss mess man
spooky okay two can play the stabbing
game
don't believe it
hey hey hey hey what the hell you get
the stab
treatment dude yeah well it's happening
what of it
yeah well how about like this
and like that and a little swish so this
no not happening
stab i stabbed the dust i stab it
i stab your dust oh crystal torso
[Music]
oh meat oh good well
goodbye i guess
oh that's very sad
oh yeah this is normal
uh yeah i don't
what did i just notice ah man i can't
really hold it missing these damn
thingies
another one was sent to the seller she
only had only spilled some soup
everyone knows what happens when you're
sent to the cellar you're never seen
again
they drain your blood your soul cursed
to wander the halls i went looking for
her and when i found her she was just
skin and bones
and gnawing on a rat carcass i suspect
it'll be my turn next well then why are
you still here
just leave just leave man
man this castle's kind of drafty oh
hello
i don't like that i don't like that at
all
what is this oh
man maybe you know maybe i shouldn't
have gotten rid of that other one that
one had a lot more potential for custom
parts
damn now i'm thinking i might have i
might have goofed it for this easy thing
hey that's convenient ah
yeah now i'm thinking i might have been
a big old goof
oh
yeah okay i'll take it i guess hello
hi
anybody at home all right
cool i guess uh you want some wine
i could have sworn that it said the
bottle was inlaid with silver
flowers oh hey
look at where i am
now where the hell was this wine thing
it was upstairs from here right let me
go down to the shop first
hey dude man hey dude man you want a
torso
hey what's up i've expanded my services
please come take a look
how did you do that this isn't expanded
at all
this isn't even close to expanded what
is this all about
dimmit rescues daughters crystallized
remains yeah no that
weird maybe i shouldn't sell it you know
or maybe i should i don't know
am i supposed to sell these things i is
there a reason to keep them
i don't know used to ward off evil
[Music]
is it supposed to be that way okay angel
statue screw that whatever get out of
here
crimson glass i'm keeping that crystal
torso i don't want to lug that thing
around
crystal skulls that movie was terrible
crystal fragment ah just get rid of it
if i if i need to keep them for whatever
reason and buy it i will
they wouldn't make it so sellable i'm
gonna keep this though and this
i wanna ward off that evil i'm skilled
at all sorts of weapons modifications
and we'll do them for a small fee
you know the dabblage is pretty good not
gonna lie that dabblage is
pretty good i'm gonna take it this
simple modification can be done in just
a moment
man you are good at that you are good my
friend you are good
i also sold my charm with it but i don't
even have enough money to get it back
yet
so i'm not gonna i guess all right i'll
be back thank you for your patronage
thank you for your whatever you do
later nerd i gotta go put a wine in a
thing
wine room boom hello you want some wine
the sanguis virtuous see it's got gold
it said silver
whoa oh
okay where's the courtyard don't have a
map
i do have a map okay cool
all right key right below oh could it be
that one
uh it's the one right below this okay
okay okay oh okay shall i give you the
tour
oh hey uh
hey oh hey how you doing hey you know
where any windows are
yeah do you know about that yeah my
friend you're the one that gets my
frames
uh so thirsty yeah whatever
how about some of this yeah meet me in
the courtyard
lady hey won't you come outside
huh yeah you won't that's what i thought
coward
that's why i thought coward that's why i
thought coward i don't
have that i mean it's a lovely courtyard
but
uh why did i come out here
oh this seems significant oh lady lady
lady lady lady
lady look at me open the door you can
obviously see me come on
lady lady lady is there anything else
down here secretive
i know that there's no point in running
after her and i just
look like a fool doing it so i'm not
gonna
even though i am right now running after
her but i'm not running after her for
her
running after just continue exploring hi
y'all i'm all reloaded
no i'm not
i am reloaded there when did i get more
ammo on this is that what the charm does
i don't know what the charm does i also
sold the other charm which was
kind of probably stupid but whatever
should i also like
move these oh
what was this oh do not throw that away
oh my god do not throw that away
we go whatever all right
wait how how am i doing that do i have
three hands
it really seems like i might have three
hands at some point there hey whatever
doesn't matter
not a big deal am i still recording
you're saying
all right i'm just doing that
preventively preemptively
pre-vented have you done to my daughter
ah what have you
done to my daughter
hello oh that don't look good
oh yeah don't mind if i do
women are blind to male advances but the
poor shall take their chances to give
their lord their bounty
sewn so that soon the wine may flow
that's not a very good poem sounds very
very men writing women you know
i don't have a reflection
just taking a little dippy dip
okay
let's just see in the hallway wait what
what is the point of
what why did i come all this way then
was there a reason for me going into the
room of blood
was there something else in the room of
blood that i could have used
oh that's actually a door the image
rescues chambers okay so this is
divatrescus chambers oh no
that's dimitrescu's chambers
okay okay okay so i have to get in here
somehow which means that i need a key
or i need to get around it in some way
back outside
there's a couple places i haven't quite
gotten yet i might be getting ahead of
myself on some of these steps here
but that's okay it happens to the best
of us
oh there's the uh cookery as they call
it
there's still still some stuff in here
but i'm gonna go back over here because
the other uh
the other daughter was also giving me
the business
other daughter you here you don't mind
if i pull a link here dee
did i get anything for these i haven't
done anything for this yet
i only have the family photo and that's
not helpful
masking angel's blinding case and only
then will you be saved okay so it's
something about doing
uh whatever these need and then i get
out there but there's something else
that i'm missing
right there's definitely something else
trying to work with my appetite oh hey
what's up how you doing
hey um
oh ha that's too close whoa what the
hell
wait whoa hey
okay that's great good thank you for the
compliment um
i still need to murder you oh god where
am i where am i where am i i'm just
going to say i'm going the same circle
i'm just going in a circle now all right
i'll be back
there's an exclamation point in here why
why
oh women are blind male
advances turn away bam
okay okay okay but the poor shall take
their chances to give their lord their
bounty sown so that soon the wine may
flow are you poor
are you the poor or are you the poor
[Applause]
all right cool we're good we're good i
knew there had to be something here
because i'm so smart
i'm so smart oh and you're so dead
bam stab the coat oh more blood
seems like a lot of
i'm waste spooked i'm just so
scared i'm terrified
oh beans
i'll probably fine i'm not gonna worry
about that squish
stab yeah
i'm sure i was about to say is that
supposed to be spooky
because it kind of was
thanks for the money whoa
hey bud hey don't don't get up
okay all right we're doing it like this
huh
that's what i thought
all right you want you want some miss me
oh you went down quick whoa hey you
are late to the party okay you don't get
to do nothing like that
and one for good measure
yeah that's what i thought yeah there
you go
anymore are you not entertained you get
to soak in the blood
you're literally drowning in the blood
isn't that what you guys want your gals
want
that's what you get for not having an
appetite
oh uh
where's your legs oh
hey oh my god you suck
don't get stabbed stabbed
no ah i'm cornered
surprisingly good strategy you know they
do
they do go down a bit it's a little more
narrow corridor for me to fight
that's right get down crystal skull hey
who the hell who
the hell where where where oh there
hey oh you okay someone's about to get
shotgunned
someone's about to get majorly thumbs up
let's stay up for good measure
step nope not today stab
and step and slam
right that was fun that was fun ladies
but i gotta go i gotta go there's the
lady of the hey
what's up how you doing boom baby
you want some more i got some more in
the form of multiple stab wounds
thank you thank you thank you very much
hey yellow
love that love that later love it
ooh what kind of blood in my eyes
ah you know i could make some why not
make some it's all good whatever
i won't get hit too much more because
i'm going to be so careful
where is this where am i
oh handy that okay
oh i see where i am oh wait that means
oh this is the scene
hello
hi
[Music]
mother miranda i regret to inform you
that ethan winters has escaped
that fool heisenberg
because he is in my castle and has
already proven too much for my daughters
to handle
when i find him
no mother miranda yes
of course i understand the importance of
the ceremony
i won't let you down
to hell with the ceremony that man
will pay for what he's done
well what about you and what you've done
where's my my daughter
daughter rose
rose hey you left this unlocked by the
way ro
we were all called by mother miranda to
decide the fate of the child's father
just thinking of that family meeting
makes me shudder
to think i'm treated like a sister to
those miscreants especially heisenberg
that riff-raff wouldn't know proper
manners if they slapped him in the face
i would have sliced him to ribbons if
mother hadn't stopped me
why why does she treat me the same as
them she gave me this castle obedient
daughters everlasting life did she not
am i not her favorite am i not special
i need a drink oh you very special
where are you where are you where are
you hey you're dressed wow it's just
very impressive very impressive very
impressive
oh whoopsies okay
wait oh can i like
i can't go back okay well i'm gonna have
to end this episode here then
oh well i'm gonna have to end
[Music]
okay well i'm gonna have to end this
episode here then because i actually
have nowhere
no idea where to go
never mind i know exactly where to go
i know perfectly understandably where
i'm supposed to go
oh hi oh
all this for a child who isn't even here
what the hell do you ungrateful
selfish wretch you come into my house
you lay your filthy man hands on
my daughters and now you even try to
steal
my property
rest while you can
go ahead do your worst that's some
respectable power right there
that's a how is my neck is what i'm
wondering about
like my neck just got slugged through of
like
four floors and i seem to be a-okay
hey let me try scoot you could just like
jump down here you know but you don't so
thanks for letting me take a nap
i guess so thank you everybody so much
for watching this has been an
illuminating episode and
very very very very very good quality
content here thank you thank you so much
for allowing me to play this
game in all of its glory and grandeur
anyway i'll uh we'll be playing more
very soon thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
the power they're so respectable
you